en amont sujet si ça vous va je voudrais
avoir votre point de vue sur cette
proposition de loi déposée par un
certain nombre de parlementaires venant
de divers partis du pack socialistes
mais aussi des républicains l'idée c'est
de légaliser le cannabis ce qui n'est
pas nouveau mais dans un encadré la
production et la vente par une espèce de
de service public avec une société
contrôlée par l'état
écoutez le projet tel que le décrit
françois michel lambert député des
bouches du rhône france est le pays en
europe à la plus forte consommation de
cannabis chez les jeunes c'est un fléau
et cette répression n'importe aucun
résultat 5 millions de consommateurs
réguliers 700000 quotidien voilà des
chiffres qui font froid et qui vont
s'approvisionner sur un marché parallèle
ça fait 50 ans l'année prochaine que la
loi de répression est en place les
résultats ne sont absolument pas là un
demi siècle donc d'autres pays ont pris
la voie de la légalisation nous nous
proposons une voix de l'égalisation mais
sous contrôle d'état avec une société
dédiée voilà ce serait une société
nationale d'exploitation du cannabis
d'où le titre de cette partie faut-il un
service public du cannabis c'est essayer
une question idiote pu être possible non
pas du tout c'est un vrai problème dans
le pays
dans la consommation qui est devenu de
masse c'est incontestable il ya plus de
30 tonnes de cannabis qui sont produits
en france aujourd'hui un bon c'est alors
le maroc et le grand pourvoyeur bien sûr
aller les grandes amitiés de chirac avec
le roi du maroc n'a pas amené pour
autant est-ce qu'on règle le problème du
rif tu me diras le roi du maroc à
l'époque avait besoin de faire payer aux
riffs un certain nombre de choses donc
il sait la région c'est la région de
grosbill cannabis bon apparemment son
fils médecis est un peu plus vigilant
sur ce qui se passe dans cette région là
mais mais bien évidemment on se dira si
le maroc était
ami de la france il ferait quelque chose
sur ce qui se passe dans la production
du cannabis
donc ce marché parallèle il est vraiment
colossal il pourrit la vie de beaucoup
de gens moi j'ai travaillé à saint denis
pendant très longtemps je peux vous dire
qu'il ya beaucoup d'endroits où vraiment
ce ce trafic
au vu de tous est véritablement un fléau
bon alors à partir de ce moment là et
comme c'était rappeler la répression n'a
rien réglé bien on a enrichi des gens
qui vivent de ce marché parallèle et les
plus haut et pour les petits salons
donne pas vraiment envie d'aller à
l'école vu qu'on gagne beaucoup de sous
en faisant le guetteur dans la journée
donc cette idée de le légaliser
mais comment qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est
pas seulement l'idée d'un d'un service
véritablement public c'est que si vous
faites le ghana biecher et que vous le
taxer pour frais toujours un marché
parallèle parce qu on s'improvise
viendra toujours là où ce sera moins
cher donc il faut faire quelque chose de
ces est extrêmement délicat et puis il
ya aussi un risque
tous ceux qui fument du cannabis
finissent pas sur des drogues dures mais
tous ceux qui sont dans les trente
durant généralement commencer par le
cannabis
donc il faut être tout à fait prudent
mais que ça pose un problème réel à
poser et qu'on peut pas balayer d'une
main en disant ah non jamais légalisé
c'est une à mon sens ce serait une
erreur en tout cas le sujet dans l'air
puisque 70 personnalités médecins élus
économistes politiques dont raphaël
glucksmann benoît hamon yannick jadot
publie une tribune chez nos confrères de
l'ops demandant la légalisation en
expliquant qu aux etats unis
la légalisation dans plusieurs états a
fait chuter la criminalité nos
internautes sont divisés sur ce sujet
faut-il aller vers une légalisation
vous êtes 47% à nous répondre oui et 53%
à nous répondre non jean
elle nous explique la légalisation
permettrait de contrôler les circuits et
d'encadrer la consommation pour claude
ce n'est pas la santé des français qui
importe mais bien un moyen
supplémentaire de taxer à lieu chavade
lasowski quel est votre point de vue et
qui se trouve pile entre la santé d'un
côté et l'économie de l'autre mais il ya
plusieurs éléments qui rentrent en
compte mon au colorado par exemple ou là
ou là où justement le cannabis est
légalisé le marché noir se maintient
parce que les produits officiels sont là
sont trop élevés par ailleurs
effectivement faut rappeler peut-être
françois michel lambert député des
bouches du rhône appartient à un
mouvement radical de gauche
lui voudrait seulement précisé voilà le
l'organisme public qui permet de
contrôler et de mettre en place une
prévention s'appelle s e
c'est à la société d'exploitation du
cannabis et le problème va être
effectivement de savoir comment on va
pouvoir expérimenter aussi parce que la
question va être la mise en place ou
comment sous quelle forme
est ce que ce sont des médecins est ce
que ce sont des doublons de social
associatif voilà la question va être
virtuellement ou les deux la question
c'est plutôt la réalisation concrète des
conditions on sait que c'est toujours le
décalage va être entre hal et les
intentions d'un côté et la réalisation
les mises en service public de l'autre
donc c'est ça la difficulté aussi enfin
il faut se projeter là dessus parce
qu'il va y avoir deux ans
d'expérimentation nous semble-t-il pour
nourrir le débat et on va évidemment
continuer le tour de table
je propose d'écouter ce point de vue
intéressant de frédéric péchenard il est
en politique aujourd'hui 1 c'est l'un
des vice présidents de la région ile de
france l air mais il est surtout ou en
tout cas aussi l'ancien directeur
général de la police nationale il était
ce matin sur rtl
et pour lui croire que la ligue à la
légalisation du cannabis faire baisser
la criminalité
c'est très naïf l'idée qui consiste à
dire que ça va permettre aux sites et
aux quartiers de sortir de la
délinquance est une idée complètement
fausse
les délinquants continueront à vendre du
carnet par ces incultes un pur parce que
les délinquants continueront à vendre de
la drogue du cannabis
et puis si par hasard ils ne le font
plus ce qui ne le ferai plus ils vont
pas aller pointer à pôle emploi
à chaque fois qu'on a réussi à
démanteler les trafics de cannabis
une cité on s'est aperçu
systématiquement à ce moment là c'est
toujours provisoire également une
augmentation du nombre d'agressions une
ondée vaut la marmite proximité
françaises implantées du cannabis dans
leur campagne avec des appellations
d'origine avoir fait un grand défenseur
que tu fumes de l'état bourguignon
hôpitaux mais moi c'est du cdu girondins
n'ont oui alors je rappelle que la
canebière à marseille
la canebière c'était le champ de
cannabis donc on replante du cannabis
sur la canebière gratuits disponibles et
là ce que dit péchenard tombe à l'eau il
faut pas le factuel
voilà la vraie solution elle est élève
ben oui hélas alors je pense qu'il y
aurait un contrecoup donc on peut
prévoir les effets tiscali dans ces gens
là ont besoin de se recycler dans
quelque chose voilà oui alors la crise
la mise pour est sur le marché de la
drogue dure elle est autrement plus âgé
que de l'ami 6 à la mi temps les pays où
l'expérience a été fait c'est quand même
relativement assez concluant en disant
que le marché a changé de structure
voilà aujourd'hui toutes les manières on
lèvera situation la pire je pense qu'il
faut expérimenter quelque chose plutôt
totalement totalisation même et vous
alexandre d'ailleurs ça ne m'amuse mois
sur la signification et idéologique de
tout ça quand même parce que c'est une
tribune dans l'obs signé par taché
catelin la france insoumise les écolos
jadot et glucksmann donc on a ce qu'est
devenue la gauche aujourd'hui l'espèce
de business d'état si un marché qu'on
peut taxer et en même temps et en même
temps du gauchisme culturel totale
puisque
on est là dedans moi et moi je crois que
des collègues à ce jeu à croire exact
représentants du gauchisme culture
je suis étonné mais heureusement sa
maman des thèmes suivants écoutez bien
sincères aux clients
ça dépend l'intérêt de la france 2 qu'il
ya des gros shows être à gauche et
découvrez travaux non et pierre bleue ce
mois je pense que je suis pas sûr que ce
soit concluant ailleurs aux cantons bas
amsterdam par exemple on nous propose de
la drogue dure dans toutes les rues pour
l avoir expérimenté donc moi je pense
que la nature des villes étant qu'il ya
enfin à l'est les cités étant ce
qu'elles sont d'un vue là les têtes d
intégration culturelle et sociale dans
lequel elles sont ce sera remplacé par
par quelqu'un d'autre doit par quelque
chose d'autre et à mon avis de plus
violents de plus dur et c'est donc je
suis absolument pas poids
il ya peut-être quelque chose qui n'a
pas été testée c'est la dpee
dépénalisation c'est à dire que tu as
pts et des consommateurs le consommateur
pour le coup parce que généralement
c'est la bourgeoisie qui fut mis à
l'essai des fils à papa qui fument des
pétards paul et moi il ya un pas que ces
cas c'est vraiment caricature de la pac
mais cette façon dont on peut faire plus
l'âge mais je pense qu'il faut pas
mettre les gens en garde à vue
d'ailleurs le rôle g
voilà je finis je pense que qu'il
faudrait mettre une amende ou au
consommateur parce que l'on vend on va
pas les mettre en garde à vue où les
flics ne le font pas ils ont autre chose
à faire donc c'est pour ça que je dis
qu'il faut dépénaliser mais remplacé sa
part une amende extrêmement forte pour
pour les consommateurs il accompagné de
mesures que la réouverture des maisons
closes qui a soupiré un petit peu les
tensions sociales dans ce pays
pourquoi pas ça c'est votre affaire
messier mais fois il faut aller jusqu'au
bout quand on va dans les deux sens
c'était je suis moins hostile mais vous
préparé cette autre je vous propose donc
de passer